>> ABSOLUTELY, THIS IS THE ROOT
OF ALL OF THESE CONVERSATIONS.
>> IT’S A SMOKE SCREEN.
NONE OF THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH RACE
WHATSOEVER.
IT’S ABOUT PROTECTING THE
AMERICAN POPULATION, PERIOD.
JOINING US NOW IS A.J.
LOUDERBACK.
THE JACKSON COUNTY SHERIFF.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US,
SHERIFF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IS IT TRUE IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN DETAINED BECAUSE
THEY’RE NOT HERE LEGALLY,
FOREIGN NASH NAME -- NATIONALS
ARE BEING RELEASED WITHOUT A
CORONAVIRUS TEST?
>> IT’S TRUE.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
IF I COULD CONTINUE, TUCKER.
THE MEMO THAT I RECEIVED THIS
LAST WEEK IT’S A DEFUND THE ICE
BY MEMO, BY MEMORANDUM SET OUT
JANUARY 20, 2021, THIS IS A
DEVASTATING DOCUMENT FOR TEXANS
AND AMERICANS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WHEN I READ THE MESSAGE AND
LOOKED AT IT, IT’S A MESSAGE TO
THE WORLD THAT YOU CAN COME HERE
ILLEGALLY, COMMIT CRIMES HERE
AND REMAIN ILLEGALLY.
>> OF ALL THINGS, THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SINCE AMERICANS ARE NOW BEING
TOLD IN THE NEAR FUTURE, WE MAY
NOT BE ALLOWED TO FLY ON
AIRPLANES WITHOUT BEING PROVEN
FREE OF THE VIRUS WITHOUT A
CERTIFICATE THAT SAYS WE’RE
NEGATIVE.
HOW IN A COUNTRY LIKE THAT CAN
WE FORGET TO TEST ILLEGAL ALIENS
FOR THE VIRUS BEFORE RELEASING
THEM?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> I’M SURE IT WAS PRESIDENT A
FORGOT ITEM.
YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW, BUT IN
THE HASTE TO OPEN THE BORDER FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY, THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I EXPECTED TO
SOME DEGREE.
WE WALKED THIS PATH FROM 2008 TO
2016.
THIS PROGRAM THAT WAS RELEASED
BY MEMORANDUM IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE PRIORITY OF THE PROGRAM IN
2014, 2015.
WHERE PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO COMMIT
CRIMES AGAINST AMERICANS.
THE COVID ISSUE OVERLOOKED
DURING THAT TIME.
SO YOU KNOW, I STRUGGLE FOR A
THOUGHT PROCESS LIKE MANY
AMERICANS AND TEXANS ON HOW
ANYONE IN THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
CONDUCT THEMSELVES IN THIS
MATTER AND PROMOTE THEMSELVES
LAWLESSLY.
SOMEBODY WILL GET HURT AND
KILLED AND PEOPLE ALLOWED TO
STAY HERE, WHICH IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
YET HERE WE SIT WITH THIS
SITUATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IN A COUNTRY WHERE WE’RE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO TO CHURCH OR
FUNERALS BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE
EFFECTS OF THIS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE EFFECTS
WILL BE?
>> IRREPARABLE HARM, TUCKER.
YES, WE’RE WORRIED.
EVERY PEACE OFFICER IN THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ATTITUDE, THE LAWLESSNESS, THE
COMPLETE ABJECT REMOVAL OF LAW.
WE HAVE FULL -- NULLIFICATION
OF THE LAW GOING ON HERE.
WE’RE GOING TO ALLOW OUR ICE
OFFICERS, USCIF, ALL AFFECTED BY
THIS MEMO, WHICH GUTS THE INA
AND HANDCUFFS THEM WHERE THEY’RE
UNABLE TO RESPOND.
SO IN LAW ENFORCEMENT HERE,
THOSE OF US THAT DON’T HAVE THE
JURISDICTION TO ENFORCE THE
FEDERAL LAWS HERE, WE’RE -- WE
CREATED A SITUATION THAT IS
UNTHINKABLE FOR THE PUBLIC.
THE PUBLIC HAS NO IDEA THE
STRENGTH OF A MEMORANDUM THAT’S
BEEN FILED HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO IT’S -- I THINK IT’S OUR JOB
AND I APPRECIATE, YOU KNOW, YOUR
PROGRAM AND INVITING ME ON HERE
TO GET THE WORD OUT AND SPREAD
WHAT IS HAPPENING BEFORE OUR
VERY EYES, WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
>> Tucker: WE APPRECIATE YOU